pourquoi les tensions non d'un cran dans
ce dossier ukrainien pourquoi les états
unis restent sourds aux affirmations de
moscou sur le retrait des troupes à la
frontière quels enjeux se cache derrière
tout cela c'est l'heure de notre
décryptage
[Musique]
est avec nous pour en parler sur se paie
tôt régis le sommier grand reporter rt
france bonsoir régis merci d'être avec
nous et emmanuel leroy président de
l'institut 17-17 bonsoir emmanuel leroy
pour nous accompagner également jacques
myard mer et l'air de maisons laffitte
bonsoir jacques myard merci d'être là
donc depuis quelques bons soirs depuis
quelques jours scénario donc à
rebondissements invente hier régis le
sommier ont parlé ensemble de détente un
ici même sur ce plateau est aujourd'hui
rebelote un joe biden qui annonce
décidément une invasion imminente un
orienté pour hier on attendait hier il
avait 10 16 février avec même des
horaires à l'appui
joe biden qui croit savoir aussi que les
russes augmentent leurs troupes alors
que ces derniers disent le contraire on
a décidément du mal à suivre on a du mal
à suivre on voit qu'on est toujours dans
une espèce de surenchère notamment de la
part de la part de la partie américaine
surenchère qui est à la fois de l'ordre
des politiques et pas que joe biden
s'est également partagé par les
démocrates et les républicains aux états
unis à quelques exceptions près bernie
sanders ou quelques ténors aussi de taux
de des deux parties et qui exprime
certaines réserves si justement sur cet
état d'esprit un peu alarmiste même très
clairement alarmiste il ya aussi
toujours la presse internationale la
presse en tout cas américaine qui qui
pousse on a l'impression que cette
musique on la connaît qu'elle a été
c'est un scénario qu'on a déjà entendu
un jeu ceux qui ont à l'époque été aux
états unis en 2003 au moment de la
guerre en irak se souviennent de ces de
cette espèce d'emphase tout à coup e on
peut se permettre de dire à peu près
tout et n'importe quoi de l'adversaire
il n'y a plus aucune mesure et en même
temps tout ça on sent bien est
encouragée par le pouvoir là là là il ya
quand même mon dd des signes
contradictoires on a dit c'est ces
escarmouches qui commença enfin en tout
cas ces échanges de tirs qui peuvent à
comment exister dans la partie est de
l'ukraine qui sont quand même inquiétant
même si il faut quand même reconnaître
que cette cette guerre larvée existe
dans l'est de l'ukraine depuis 2000
il y a eu il ya eu quand même au fil
depuis 2014 en plusieurs périodes de
tension et des périodes d'accalmie dans
ces zones là il ya toujours des
tranchées de part et d'autre on est
toujours dans une situation qui est
instable donc là oui en effet il ya des
échanges de tirs aujourd'hui caractérisé
la sur les russes par le fait est que
les comment les manoeuvres militaires ce
qui s'est passé mercredi qui était quand
même assez décisif c'est avec les
manoeuvres militaires entre la russie
entre l'armée russe et l'armée
biélorusses ont pris fin donc du coup
une partie des trous en effet sont
revenus dans leurs casernements il a les
troupes étaient également mobilisés en
crimée donc il ya aussi une fin annoncée
est prévue de ces exercices donc là les
américains continuent à on ne comprend
pas très bien le problème en fait c'est
qu'on comprend pas très bien ce que
cherche comment joe biden à ce stade
parce que en étant tout en étant
présidents d'amérique américain il ya
des raisons pour lesquelles c'est
comment cette crise existe mais quel
était l'intérêt pour lui de prévoir
comme vous l'avez dit mercredi matin à
l'aube il y aura une intervention
quel était l'intérêt de mettre en avant
la crédibilité
non mais mais mais c'est toujours que ce
soit le sun en angleterre où quelques
journaux comme ça qui se décrit bibi
lisent en donnant leur en 10 ans à 3
heures du matin attention il va y avoir
des attaques de chars certes mais joe
biden le président américain est comme
qu'en plus ça ne se produit pas on finit
par se poser des questions jacques myard
régis sont menées
nous parler d'une petite musique
évidemment avec entre guillemets cette
petite hystérie américaine et anglo
saxon notamment dans la presse alors
c'est pas un concerto de violon c'est la
grosse caisse comment vous expliquez
cela vous vous vous y croyez justement
cette invasion imminente
écoutez savez il peut toujours y avoir
des dérapages et des poteaux mais ce qui
est certain c'est que l'évangile selon
la cia il ya longtemps que je ne crois
plus que je ne crois plus c'est sans
doute un évangile je dirais apocryphe
donc il est évident que les états unis à
la tête de l'otan qui est une machine
américaine veulent reconstituer un
ennemi des halles ils ont eu des
déboires fort en afghanistan ni me le
montrer parce que il ya savez au sein de
l'union européenne beaucoup de
divergences si vous prenez la pologne si
vous prenez les états balle ils ont une
plainte de l'ex urss et de la russie de
poutine aujourd'hui il n'en demeure pas
moins que la france a toujours dit qu'il
s'était et qu'elle s'opposera à l'entrée
de l'ukraine dans l'otan c'est la clé
c'est la clé et donc c'est ce que roche
eir côté d'asus tic parce que depuis des
décennies depuis 30 ans les russes
disent attention la preuve de l'otan
près des frontières va constituer vous
verrez une tension forte et que c'est
une faute et on peut le comprendre
on peut parfaitement le comprendre je
suis de ceux en tant que gaulliste qui
pensent que la russie fait partie de
l'équilibré 1 mais de grâce cessons à
longueur de temps de faire d'elle ou
d'essayer de faire d'elle un idéal donc
aujourd'hui je regrette d'ailleurs que
le président macron ne t'a pas un peu du
poing sur la tête sur la table mais il
est dans une contradiction parce que il
c'est un euro lattre convaincu et ne t'a
pas du prince oualata pour des remarques
à maintenant ça suffit
nous nous opposons à l'entrée
de l'ukraine dans le temps et je pense
que ça c'est la clé je dirais de la
baisse de tension ce qui ne veut pas
dire ensuite qu'il faut pas trouver des
solutions pour john bass et ccc hier
d'escarmouches perpétuelle qui peut
créer des tensions et surtout qui peut
tuer les civils donc la clé c'est en
réalité le fait que l'ukraine ne doit
pas rentrer dans l'otan parce que ce
serait mon regard de la réussite une
provocation
difficile à admettre et c'est ça le
problème manifestement il ya vraiment
une lecture totalement différente parce
que il ya cette ligne rouge aux russes
dont vous nous parler cette extension de
l'otan et puis selon effectivement la
version américaine anglo saxon
occidentale même française il ya voilà
le cette envie corée la russie de
recréer l'union soviétique d'ailleurs
les échanges de tirs dans le donbass
avons parié du don bassin jacques myard
boris johnson qui accuse aujourd'hui la
réussite provocation visant à
discréditer kiev je cite et à justifier
une intervention
effectivement on peut se demander
l'intérêt port est absolument la russie
à faire s'intaller clair il est clair
que dans cette affaire de l'ukraine ni
l'ukraine ni la russie n'ont intérêt à
cette guerre exemple ce serait
jean n'en suis moins sûr que j'en suis
moins sûr que vous je crains et c'est le
jeu que l'on quel on assiste d'ailleurs
et qui se souvient en parler à un
instant toute la propagande de guerre
qui se fait aujourd'hui provient des
états unis et de londres et de
l'angleterre de la grande bretagne est
manifestement il ya une volonté de nuire
à l'intérêt même pour les autres
peut-être que la situation interne aux
états unis n'est pas si bonne que cela
et que une guerre constituera un
excellent dérivatif donc ça c'est une
hypothèse qui est en ligne de mire
l'autre hypothèse et c'est que et on
n'en parle pas souvent la moitié de
l'armée ukrainienne est concentré dans
le dos basse prête à partir à l'assaut
comme elle l'était déjà il ya un an en
avril 2000 2021 aux côtés de cette armée
ukrainienne il y a des forces spéciales
américaines anglaises canadienne
polonaise qui sont sur le terrain et ce
sont ces sur ses forces spéciales là que
compte l'otan pour déclencher les
provocations qui entraînerait une
réaction russe et c'est pour cela que
monsieur baydan monsieur johnson et les
journaux qui le reçoit affidés annonce
que la guerre va démarrer dans 18 heures
12 heures 14 c'est que il attend que
leurs forces spéciales agit sur le
terrain mais j'ai l'impression que les
russes vont jouer une pression très
forte pour que cet assaut ne démarre pas
je répondu rajoutera et pardonnez moi je
vais vous rajoutez juste un mot pour
revenir sur ce que disais donc que
monsieur jacques maire un instant bien
sûr il est évident que l'ukraine ne doit
pas entrer dans l'otan mais la véritable
condition du retour de la paix en
ukraine c'est le respect des accords de
minsk il suffit que monsieur eddeh de
quitter par les pardonner
au menu de l'eau news aujourd'hui
justement mais je voudrais vous montrer
des images justement à kiev 1 pendant
que les anglo saxons bondissent voilà
l'idée d'une invasion imminente un
regard des ces centaines de manifestants
alors on se dit ils manifestent contre
la guerre on ferait bien non tout
simplement contre la réforme des tables
sans une mesure de politique intérieure
dont on est on est très très loin
oui j'allais vous demander au nom
sonnait comme en afrique ce décalage
entre ces personnes regardent et on se
croirait à paris les petites
manifestations
là on n'est pas dans un pays qui va
enfin qui semble en tout cas les
habitants n'ont pas cette conscience
on est dans un pays qui traverse une
crise économique très grave dans lequel
effectivement il ya beaucoup de
contestations avec elle le gouvernement
des vingt ce qui n'est pas sûr
d'ailleurs d'être reconduit aux affaires
et que dans lequel beaucoup d'opposants
ont été arrêtés aussi enfin il faut
regarder la réalité ukrainienne comme
une économie qui est en berne depuis 30
ans en plus l'économie qui n'arrive pas
à décoller donc évidemment cette tension
et cette crise ne vont pas améliorer les
choses pour l'économie ukrainienne qui
dans le même temps voix des pays comme
la pologne ou la roumanie prospérer à
ses frontières avoir des taux de
croissance importants et donc voilà
l'ukraine est à nouveau plombé par cette
se pare d un enjeu qui finalement la
dépasse puisque on sent bien que les
intérêts américains dans l'histoire
c'est pas simplement protéger l'ukraine
les américains en plus agite le chiffon
rouge 2 de la sacro-sainte intégrité de
l'ukraine sur laquelle il faut
absolument comment intervenir si la
russie envahi et puis dans le même temps
10 nous n'en verrons nous n'en verrons
aucun soldat ils ont même retiré leur
186,3 de soldats d'ukraine en disant on
va les redéployer à côté on va envoyer
un contingent de 3000 soldats en pologne
tout simplement pour respecter les
accords de l'otan qui stipule que comme
en bas dans l'otan finalement il faut
mettre des amendes et des soldats
américains pour défendre comme il ya des
stones des français en estonie où finir
il ya des français en roumanie pour me
courte pour dire en défense si les
russes attaque ces pays là à la suite de
l'ukraine on peut imaginer ou dans le
même temps eh bien il se met en position
de tuer des français des anglais des
américains voilà donc la la c'est là le
le rôle défensif de l'otan mais
l'ukraine ne fait absolument pas partie
de l'otan donc il n'y a pas de raison
donc d'un ce et c'est toujours le même
problème avec les américains ils sont
toujours très très fort pour déclencher
des guerres qui soit disant comment
détermine le l'avenir du monde
souvenez-vous avec saddam hussein
souvenez vous également nous après avec
kadhafi ou tout à coup des gens qu'on a
toléré pendant 30 ou 40 ans et avec qui
on s'est très bien entendu deviennent
les nouveaux hitler parce que le la
donne du moment faut fait qu'il faut
intervenir mais pour les américains ça
ne se passe jamais sur leur territoire
c'est toujours très loin c'est toujours
quelque chose qui ne m'ont pas avoir à
subir nous on européen on nous devons
regarder l'ukraine comme faisant comme
un pays très proche de l'europe voire
faisant partie de l'europe et dans une
guerre en ukraine aura des conséquences
sur sur l'europe aura des conséquences
sur ce continent elle n'aura pas de
conséquences sur l'avenir des états unis
donc là c'est toujours la même chose et
donc oui pourquoi pourquoi continuer à à
comment agité les choses je pense qu'il
ya un comment monsieur byden a commis
deux erreurs fondamentales donc ça a été
ça a été évoqué ce retrait calamiteux
d'afghanistan qui a été
co conduit à une dégradation de son
comment de son image au niveau de
l'opinion publique est également s'est
passé avec la subtilisation du contrat
comment australien oui bon il a montré
qu' il traitait extrêmement mal ses
alliés peut-être là aussi il ya de la
part des américains de volonté de
resserrer les rangs autour d'eux et de
justement face à une cause commune et du
coup l'ukraine devient le prétexte
que bien évidemment l'otan est une
machine américaine
et donc elle s est la première
organisation politique en europe celle
de la défense de plus il y a un problème
majeur aux etats unis c'est qu'il
n'existe pas une seule politique
étrangère et le président pendant la
tête effectivement et en faisant ses
déclarations essaye de regrouper
l'ensemble des divers éléments qui font
la politique étrangère que ce soit le
pentagone que ça soit la cia nsa soit le
commerce on s'assoit break
donc il essaie de remettre tout le monde
au garde à vous parce que il a perdu
l'aura du chef en afghanistan
c'est aussi simple que ça il faut le
savoir mais ce qui est certain c'est que
aujourd'hui une guerre en europe et on
le traîne car selon me la faire et
d'ailleurs les ukrainiens sont beaucoup
plus calme semble le dire les américains
mais il est vrai que ces images c'était
le sens de deux parce que quand on est
au bord de la guerre on va peut-être pas
manifester contre la réforme bintec
saint malo les des articles de la presse
française montrent qu' il ya un certain
calme bien sûr on va vous dire il ya les
aprilia et cetera j'ai entendu quelques
papiers sur des radios d'état mais il
n'en demeure pas moins que aujourd'hui
il ya une volonté américaine de m les
alliés européens au garde à vous ce que
je regrette c'est que le président de la
république française de nice pas
attendait maintenant ça suffit mais
pourquoi il peut pas le dire parce qu'il
prétend être un euro je dirais convaincu
et donc il fait la quadrature du cercle
parce que les polonais peut pas être
d'accord avec ce qu'il peut dire ou avec
les allemands il ya aussi cette histoire
du gaz donc on voit très bien en réalité
l'union européenne c'est le je dirais
les forces centrifuges en permanence
tout la nécessité d'avoir une politique
nationale propre à la france
mais elle aura le mot de la fin pour
vous on arrive déjà les femmes ce
décryptage justement ce qui s'est passé
à l'onu la russie vous me parlez des
accords de minsk justement accuse
l'ukraine de ne pas respecter les
accords 2 min c'est là aussi une des
clés peut-être c'est la clé du confit ce
la clé de résolution du conflit si
demain monsieur tanner ce qu'il applique
les accords de minsk 2 tels qu'ils ont
été signés tels que l'ukraine d assigner
est telle que la france et l'allemagne
en sont les garants aux côtés de la
russie la paix sera inévitablement de
retour en ukraine pour tout le monde et
c'est impérativement ce qu'il faut faire
il ya un point sur lequel j'aurai quand
même
intervenir pour revenir sur ce qui était
dit au départ parce que c'est gravissime
les bombardements quotidiens qui dure
depuis huit ans sur les populations
civiles du dôme bas ce sont des crimes
de guerre se sont pas ceux sont pas des
opérations militaires ce sont des crimes
de guerre quand une armée viser
délibérément des populations civiles ça
s'appelle des crimes de guerre qui sont
justement banni par les accords de minsk
et c'est eux qu'il faudrait respecter
pour faire revenir la paix dans ce pays
merci manuel leroy merci régis au
sommier merci également à vous jacques
myard